-Last week, during
a Coronavirus Task Force
briefing at the White House,
the U.S. surgeon general,
Jerome Adams,
revealed that the coronaviru
is disproportionately
affecting Black
and Hispanic Americans
and, to fix that, Adams said
people of color need
to "Step up
and take responsibility
for keeping themselves healthy."
He added...
Here, with more on that,
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin,
with a segment called
"Amber's Minute of Fury."
[ Heavy metal theme plays
[ Flames crackling ]
-Fool,
I know you did not just
get up in front
of your little white friends
and blame the spread
of the coronavirus
on minorities.
Damn!
There is nothing
this administration won't blam
on people of color.
I'm surprised they didn't give
a press conference
on Easter
to point out the fact that
[ changes accent ]
the worst jelly beans
are the Black ones.
Now, I can see this type
of thing coming
from a member of Trump's staff
but I did not see it comin
from a Jerome.
A Chad; a Tyler, maybe.
But a Jerome?
You friggin' idiot.
You are parroting classic
right-wing talking points.
If Billboard had a chart
for racist talking points,
"Minorities just don't
take care of themselves"
would be number 2, right after
"Never talk about the real roo
of the problem --
systemic racism."
Tsk. Y'all, this man went
on national television,
flanked by the world's
most famous racists,
and tried to get minoritie
to stop the spread by saying..
[ As Adams ]
Do it for your abuela.
Do it for Big Mama.
Now, when he was talking
to white people about it,
did he say, "Do it for Pee-Paw"?
Did he say,
"Do it for Gam-Gams"?
No! Because you can talk
to white people regular,
but when you talk to minorities,
you have to do an impersonation,
or we can't understand you
And reporters are like,
"Black people are getting
sicker than white people.
Mm, anyway, on to sports."
But you can't do that!
'Cause there are
no sports anymore, but also,
if you want to point out
a disparity like that,
you have to say what caused it
It's redlining.
It's doctor bias.
It's systemic racism!
And, if you don't know
what those things mean,
it's probably also you!
America is set up specifically
to do this to Black people
Bad things always affect
Black people worse
and Americans always act
like it's Black people's fault
If Nancy Kerrigan was Black,
people would've been like...
[ changes accent ]
Well, why were you
in that pipe's way?
Also, if you're gonna
hang out in this rink,
you need to buy something.
Bad things always affect u
disproportionately.
Except sunburns.
Now, if it was only
Black people who got sunburns,
sunblock would not exist.
Well, it would,
but you wouldn't be able
to get it at like Walgreens.
You'd only be able to get it
at like a Lee's Beauty Supply,
which is fine, 'cause I wa
going there, anyway.
Now, the coronavirus is
affecting Black people
disproportionately.
That is a fact,
but here's the thing, Jerome
You can't run around sayin
that fact out loud
because we want
the government to fix it!
And, if you tell Americans
it mostly affects Black people
folks will be
outside in a big pile,
French kissing strangers
[ Striking palm ] tomorrow
No one would care!
You need to tell people
this coronavirus
only affects old white men
and white children.
That's how you get people
to care.
We should be calling this
the J. Crew virus.
[ changes accent ]
"The J. Crew virus --
Is it serious?"
Well, you can only get it
if you've been
in a J. Crew the past year
"[ Gasp ] The past year?!
I go every day!
They're my emergency contact!"
Now, here's the deal.
When you have a job that allow
you to work from home,
you can stay home.
It just so happens that the jobs
that have been deemed
essential --
healthcare providers,
bus drivers, subway operators,
food delivery people --
a lot of these jobs are done
by Black people,
and that's messed up,
in several ways,
but I'll just say this.
Minorities are dying so people
can eat Domino's Pizza
in their pajamas.
That's effed up!
In part, because Pizza Hut
is infinitely better.
I'm right, and I don't have time
to argue with you about it
People are dying.
Now, I'm working from home
but almost every Black perso
I know is at work right now,
talking about how spoiled I am
And they're right!
Mmm.
But, really, there's a lot
of Black and Brown people I love
who have been at work every da
since this thing started
and, real talk,
I am losing sleep,
terrified for them.
I wanna come on the show,
doing a silly sketch
where I'm dressed as a doughnut,
talking about
"Amber ate my family,"
but, instead,
I gotta be doing this
because I'm a human being
and I live in this world
and I wanna, in some tiny way,
try and undo the danger
you put us all in
when you talk like a friggin
idiot on national television
This has been
"Amber's Minute of Fury"!
♪♪♪♪